and
we going
live
just for you
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
what's up y'all this is ripping with
griffin coming to you live
full of facts
today's episode is national book day
national favorite book day
dc universe has a 10-year plan we'll see
what that's about brittany kreiner got
sentenced to nine years
and kevin durant is acting up again
this is riffing with griffin starring
eric griffin and thank you for being
here
[Music]
[Music]
yes
in full effect
this is riffing with griffin starring
eric griffin thanks for being here and
this episode is brought to you by
helix sleep
helix sleep um helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com griffin with helix
better sleep
starts now
what's up y'all welcome to riffin with
griffin um
you know how we do it uh there's the
main titles uh make sure you
hit that subscribe button make sure you
subscribe
uh if you want to send me some music
send me some music too that i could jam
to at the end of the episode
um make sure you check me out on twitch
because i'm on twitch daily i'll be
going on twitch right after the episode
that's how i do it play a lot of call of
duty actually i've been playing i've
been playing call of duty i've been
playing fortnite and i've been playing
destiny again so i got uh added some
games to my thing and if you just want
to support the show i sometimes i put my
gaming videos on whatever videos i can i
put up on the patreon but you can
support me
on patreon if you want to or you could
be a youtube member right here you could
join be a member there you could be a
super follower on tw twitter if you
wanted to or you could be a subscriber
on twitch any which one of those ways
that you say you want to support me
monthly uh you know helping me out to
make the show better and just to help me
out for the free content i would i would
appreciate that thank you
very much
so
um nothing major to report uh
i i believe today is let me see what's
today
oh man this is crazy you know what today
is today is
my two month anniversary
that's actually kind of crazy i just
realized that
[Laughter]
two month anniversary of the wedding i
think that's so funny me and rachel
didn't even like we didn't even we
didn't even say that to each other you
know
i should actually i'm actually gonna
facetime i'm actually gonna facetime
rachel right now
uh even though you guys won't be able to
see her but you'll be able to hear her
so you can like uh
you know let's see let's see what she
has to say
uh babe
yes i'm on my podcast right now live and
i just i forgot to i forgot to say this
to you today let me put my rachel thing
on the screen rachel
uh you're actually not on screen well
actually i can put you on
if i do like this hey there's rachel
everybody that's watching on youtube oh
my god please stop
but babe i just wanted to tell you happy
two month anniversary
[Laughter]
it's our two month anniversary
well i love you two months worth all
right babe i love you too all right
i love you so much okay please don't
start getting emotional i'm on i'm live
on youtube right now babe okay
so we're not going to cry right now
[Laughter]
okay woman bye i love you so much okay
bye bye
[Laughter]
oh man
chick is crazy
so anyways oh and thank you mkels for
the super chat
um yeah so just two months anniversary
two months of marriage you know
you know people always ask is it
different marriage is different guys i
just want to let you know people that
are married you understand i'm in early
parts of it right now but we've been
together now you know six seven years
now so but like the marriage when you
make it official and tight and you wake
up and you look at this person you're
like oh this is my person you know you
know there's no getting out of this so
it's like you know and there's like a
um
it's like a commitment level that you're
like all right
i'm here you're with it you feel i don't
know you feel more secure you feel i
don't know it's a it's actually a good
feeling you know i'm just i'm not just
saying that you know it's actually a
really good feeling guys so
shout out to all you people out there
who are uh getting married or about to
be married or whoever is already married
yeah all right so um man you know bunch
of stuff going on today
today is also
today is also national
book lovers day or something like that
one of those um
book lovers day or whatever it is and i
just wanted to i don't know i i listen
to audio books i don't know if you guys
listen to audiobooks
um even even before that my 200th
episode is coming up so i need ideas i
need you guys to send some things in the
comments like if if should i have a
guest which guest should i have
um you know for the 200 episodes you
know so that's great maybe i should have
bobby and steve on together again for
the 200th episode or i don't know what
do you guys think who should i get or
you know what should i do
so think about that so 200 wow i can't
believe this my little podcast has gone
200 episodes um
but it's national book day so i i have a
audio audible subscription i like
listening to audiobooks i actually
rarely listen to music now in my car
even though i have apple music and i
have spotify i listen to a lot of
audiobooks and i'm partial to partial to
science fiction so i love science
fiction books
i love fantasy i love like dragons and
magic and witches and vampires that's my
favorite type of books
so on national uh you know
whatever you call it day
national book day i just want to give
you some of my favorite books some of my
favorite books
i love the harry potter series
the harry potter series is great it
starts a little childish first few uh
books and then it really starts to get
good you know
prisoner of azkaban starts to get a
little dark but then like in uh part
four
uh the goblet of fire that's when it
really becomes like oh this is some real
like people are dying and stuff so uh i
think she did a great job and i love the
harry potter series and i love watching
the movies that's a great series if you
want to read a great series of the
famous series that are made that have
become movies out there
um i liked the harry potter one um you
know guilty pleasure guys i love
twilight
i'm sorry i'm sorry but i love i love
twilight i i love the books uh they're
very you know i just i love the books
they're very romantic books actually
it's a very romantic book um
[Music]
and i and i also love watching the
movies like i had this thing where if i
start watching a movie
uh like let's say if i turn twilight on
next thing you know i'm watching all of
them
that's just what i do i did it the other
day with star trek so weird because i
got the paramount plus app and then they
had the star trek series on there and so
i watched the first star trek movie next
thing you know i'm like eight movies
deep
so that's just something i do and i
really enjoy watching harry potter over
and over again and i enjoy watching uh
that um another good
good books are lord of the rings those
are actually great books hobbit and all
those books those are great books but
i'm gonna give you some books that you
may not know about like i'm gonna tell
you about some good series that i love
okay
so uh
um
one of them one of them's called the
magician's apprentice
uh the magician's apprentice i wonder if
i should go to this uh
it's a novel
um wait there's actually so many
magicians apprentices
there's so many magician apprentices
books wait let me go to my let me go to
my
let me go to my freaking what do you
call it here so i can tell you guys
well yeah the one i like is by raymond
e
e feist or feast i think it's feist
raymond feist let me see let me look him
up raymond e feist yeah that's his books
yeah man
so i and i i'm telling you these books
are
he wrote this first book i believe in
1982
yeah man
yeah he wrote this first book in 1982
and it's um
oh man wow this is that that's crazy
yeah knight oh would let's see mr
purchase mass market paperback jam oh no
okay he wrote his first book in 1982 but
i believe this there's a
he created this world called medic medic
mia whatever it is and it's like this
rift war saga what it's called and you
know this the first book in the series
is called the magician's apprentice and
it just follows this this
it follows this
um guy
this guy who becomes
he he trains as a magician but it spans
over like 20 years
so
look it up and it's actually a great
series and it just kept going and going
and going and you know he you know after
he finished a chunk of the series he
wrote another series in the same world
and so forth and so on and he just
recently started writing some new books
that i actually got and it was those
weren't as good as his original books
but i really enjoy that that series
um
so check that guy out and another series
that i really enjoy and i love this guy
man and he's such a weird dude i
actually hit him up on facebook and i
was trying to get him on my podcast but
he was like i don't know he was just
telling me in a text he was just like
you know if you want me to come on i
mean i stutter a lot i like you know
he just was explaining to me that he is
a weird communicator and i thought it
was so bizarre for a guy
who is so prolific as a writer his name
is christopher g knuddle
christopher g nuttle man let me let me
go to his thing right now christoph
christopher
g
nuttle man this dude
wow i don't even know what to say he has
so
many
books man he has so many series going on
at once
it's hard to even understand how he
could keep them all together in his
brain
um
[Music]
i don't know how he does it but he has
this series called
and i've talked about this before
but i just i want to talk about it again
because i love this guy you know and i
actually should get him on the podcast
regardless i'm you know i'm trying to
look this up and it's like
um
[Music]
oh here we go here we go here we go i
want to look at like
all right here oh here he is author oh
here we go he has his own website
perfect
uh chris hanger is what it's called his
official website the official website by
christopher g nuttles called
chrishanger.net
anyway he's got a series called the
school of magic
and it's like a 20 book series man but
it's so in-depth so intense i love it
and i love a book with a good heroine
so anyway the book is about this girl
who gets like a demon
a sorcerer from another world makes a
deal with a demon and he he pulls this
her from earth okay
pulls her into this sort of like
dungeons and dragons world of this sort
of like medieval times place and she's
pulled there and a sorcerer saves her
and then sends her to magic school okay
and then it just goes on this long
journey and then what i like about it is
she starts to add like
modern day stuff into this world you
know like she like brings a bra she says
hey
she invents the bra and she like uh
it's just stuff like that you know where
she brings like you know the printing
press and the steam engine and it is
changing this world of like this
medieval sort of times but anyway
politics intrigue
but he has so many books man so he has
that series he has enough he has like
three or four other series he also
writes a lot of like science fiction
like spaceship like like aliens have
come to earth and those type of uh books
and so i've i've started like three or
four of his series and they just i just
can't i don't know how he does it i
don't know how he keeps all that stuff
in his head
uh you know because it's all happening
simultaneously because he he comes out
with books all the time so shout out to
christopher g nuttle i love those books
so on national book day that's what i
wanted to uh come out with to let you
guys know
you know what i mean so if you oh and
the reason why i'm bringing this up is
like chat tell me your favorite books i
would like some recommendations for
books if you're into the genre that i'm
into i i like i say i like sci-fi i also
love vampire books i've writ i've read
as many vampire books as i can i love a
good vampire story man i just love it
they're always like dark i like the
darker the better too i like the dark
ones and i also like the ones that are
just more like teenage campy but those
are still sometimes good too so make
sure let me know about what books you
like put it in not just the chat but put
it in the comments for me please tell me
hey i like this book and that kind of
stuff and also put in the comments you
know put in like for episode 200 have
this person on for episode 200 you know
what i mean and let's see uh where we
could go with that but yeah i love uh i
love all that
on national book day
so congrats on that all right
all right so
sports news uh as you guys know man
kevin durant is at it again
so apparently
kevin durant
yesterday or today
he tells the owner if you don't trade me
i'll stay but you have to fire steve
nash and sean marks the gm
to me this is bananas man the whole
thing is bananas it reeks of
just the drama and unprofessionalism of
the whole thing
i don't know where this is gonna go i
don't know where it's gonna go it's hard
to like you know but any but i love the
drama actually you know i love it
because like we're still i love the nba
and we're still talking about the nba in
the off season the nfl is about to start
and i think that the interest in the nba
is that is that it's as high as it's
been in a long time because it's going
all into the off season now we have to
ask ourselves is the kevin durant
in the nets uniform as has it been uh
a failure it's hard to say man you know
year one they they get him and they give
him 38 million dollars to rehab
think about that
they signed him to a contract
it was something like two or three years
he couldn't even play he made 38 million
dollars
then he comes back to next year he
doesn't play a lot of games but he plays
enough games they go they go they don't
go deep into the playoffs they lose in
the second round to
the bucks
and by the way
you know game seven his toes on the line
they end up losing in overtime but kyrie
irving gets hurt but when kyrie irving
and him were playing with like a limited
james harden at the time
dude they were they were beating the
bucks 30 40 points
and then
they don't uh kyrie gets hurt and then
they go to game seven and they lose the
bucks go on to win the championship
and then you have this year
where they get swept
but then there was all the drama with
james harden and then they got ben
simmons and then then you're hearing
these reports now that ben simmons
they were in some kind of some sort of
text chain and kevin durant was like yo
you're gonna play and then
ben simmons just leaves the chat like
what
so that's what's being out there i've
been watching a couple of sports shows
and they're talking about that so i mean
i'm not gonna put it all on kevin durant
like he's like some sort of crazy person
no i think kevin durant you know
you know he wanted to go to the nets he
wanted to play with kyrie irving and
then uh kovitt hit and then like kyrie
herve is like i don't want to play then
the nets are like then you're not going
to play at all then they cave and said
okay now you could play and then it was
like this back and forth and now they're
like we're not signing you to a
long-term deal and then kevin durant's
like now i sign kevin durant signed a
four-year deal and so
kyrie irving doesn't have a four-year
deal then they trade james harden to get
ben simmons we don't know if that guy's
gonna play or not and then like you know
he co-signs uh uh steve nash being a
coach
you know he's like all right you want to
play you know he's like you know he
co-signs that he's like all right steve
nash you know i think he we don't need a
coach that's what him and uh kyrie
irving said we don't need to coach now
they got slapped and woken up like oh
yeah bro you need a coach you need a
coach you need somebody with a strong
personality strong will with a strong
scheme and game plan and practice and so
they realized after two years or three
years whatever it is
they realize steve nash he's not
experienced enough to coach a
championship team so i'm okay with him
being like all right he's get somebody
else in here because i want to win so
i'm okay with that but but you know i'm
not okay with him like he signed his
contract and he has to understand that
if they can't get good value for him
they can't trade him i'm with this guy
you know the owner is like yo i support
my staff i think sean marks made a great
team he built a championship team i mean
that team could have won the
championship if if healthy
and even this team would ben simmons
kevin durant and kyrie irving i i think
they'd be favored to win the
championship right or at least win the
east right they'd be favored so i mean i
think sean marx is doing a great job so
i don't know what the hell is uh you
know what he's doing but i think this is
all like one i feel like it could be a
ploy
all this could be so he could get kyrie
irving a four-year deal so i think that
he's like yo i'll stay fire the coach
fire the gm
and i think the ultimatum is gonna be
just give my boy a contract
so we could be here we could be here for
the next four years and try to win
championships and so we're done right
maybe it's behind the scenes he's like
why'd you get ben simmons get rid of
that dude you know or who knows but the
whole thing's a mess
it's a mess but like we'll see what
happens my prediction is
start of the season start a season game
one kevin durant's going to be with the
nets
unless there is some team that is
willing to give up the farm but then why
would he want to go to that team see
there's a lot of factors let's say kevin
durant's like i want to trade
is his main thing
i don't want to play with the nets
and i want to get out of here at all
costs well that's easy to do probably
okay
but if his main thing is like
i want to win a championship well you
can't trade him to some team and they
give up everything and then now who's he
going to play with he is 30 something
years old coming you know he's coming
off acl surgery and constant injury so
his window to win a championship isn't
very large so obviously he doesn't want
to like yeah don't just trade me but
make sure i have a championship team i'm
going to so that's a difficult situation
and then that's like we want to get
equal value we're not gonna we're not
gonna trade arguably the greatest player
in the game
top three for sure we're not going to
trade you away for nothing we got to get
something for you
so
that's that situation too
so it's like really awkward situation
i believe he's going to end up with the
nets i think they're going to work it
out i think this billionaire owner is
going to go to him and be like all right
i think one they're going to fire steve
nash and i think they should he's not
experienced enough
i think steve nash eventually is going
to be a good coach just like jason kidd
in jason kidd's first few years it was
rocky
he you know
he went from here to there then he and
then it worked out you know then he
finally figured it out after a while it
takes time and experience so i think
steve nash needs to go they'll get
somebody in probably some veteran coach
i don't know maybe they'll get phil
jackson to come out to woodworks if
anybody can deal with personalities
that's phil jackson that's what they
should do they should they should
offer him the farm man come coach these
guys so we'll see what happens but i i
my prediction is he's with the nets i
think they cave and maybe give kyrie a
two-year deal or something
i think that uh and they all start
that year if anything they may try to
trade ben simmons but i feel like
there's some kind of restriction that
they can't i'm not sure about that i
don't know i'm not an expert in that
stuff but i think that the all three
guys end up day one with a new coach and
it's all and then they go for the
championships we'll see
we
shall see but the whole thing seems like
it seems crazy to me you know what i
mean it just seems crazy when you look
at these um you know
he has this face-to-face meeting with
the owner and
he reiterated his trade requests and
informed the owner that he needs to
choose between him or the pairing of
general manager and sean marx
co and coach chief nash
so it's like you know he's trying to
strong-arm and it's like you know it's
like durant's like i'm not getting what
i want i want out of here and i want to
go to a championship all right i can see
that that can't happen so if you want me
to stay i need you to do this get rid of
that guy and that guy it's sort of like
a consolation kind of like you know he's
just swinging his dick around you know
what i mean like all right you want me
to stay we'll do this and so now you got
this billionaire fighting with you got a
millionaire fighting with a billionaire
and we'll see who wins that battle you
know
um you know what i mean so
i i hope it doesn't i'm okay with the
drama now
i'm okay with this drama
but
i don't want it to carry over into the
season like i wouldn't want there to be
a stalemate where kevin durant is like
i'm not gonna play
i don't think he's gonna do that
at this point though what does he have
to lose he already looks bad enough for
everything else right he already is the
villain he's already accepted that i'm a
villain whatever you call me soft for
going to golden state fine i want to
leave here now whatever you guys going
to say you're going to say i got my two
championships whatever so at this point
if he's like you know what i'ma sit out
what if he sits out
i don't know i mean it's still like that
sucks for the nets to be like well now
we have to trade him for what nothing so
i don't know
i don't know what's gonna happen but i
really do feel like if if you if i was a
betting man i would bet that
the nets and kevin durant are gonna work
this out steve nash is gonna get fired
and they're gonna have and they're gonna
start the season with those three guys
and whatever bench they can put together
and we'll see what happens with that
all right everybody let's talk about
helix sleep okay
you know we got to pay these bills and i
like healing sleep i actually have a
healing sleep mattress when every time i
go to the doctor or go to my health
place i like to go they ask me three
things are you exercising what are you
eating and do you get enough sleep sleep
is super important and a good mattress
really helps that situation and i have a
good mattress helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and we and
three and two free pillows
all right that's part of the deal uh
helix is a premium mattress brand
man they they did they do this sleep
quiz which i think is the coolest thing
they match you with the right mattress
that for how you sleep you tell them if
you know if your body type too you're
heavy set or you sleep on your side your
back sleeper your stomach sleep whatever
however you sleep
they work with you with their
sleep quiz to figure out
what it's all about man
uh helix mattresses are american-made
and come with a 10 to 15 year warranty
depending on the model and remember you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk free if you don't love it
i know you're going to love it guys but
if you don't they will pick it up for
you and give you a refund
you don't want to take my word for it go
to helix has been awarded the number one
mattress picked by gq and wired magazine
it's even recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine
and go-to solutions for improving your
sleep wow
that's a new fact i didn't know about so
that's that i mean that's and i'm not
surprised
like i said helix is offering up to two
hundred dollars plus free pillows go to
helixsleep.com griffin
with helix better sleep
starts
now
okay what else is going on in the world
man what else is going on in the world
you know we had our book club
um
you know i should start a book club on
my patreon you know i could get some
books i love some good books but you
know you know another big thing that's
going on in the world right now man is
this uh
this brittany griner stuff man
so i don't know if you guys know
uh brittany griner the
basketball player she was stopped and
she first of all she's lived in russia
now for like eight years or something or
played for the russian national not
national team but she's played in russia
basketball because that's where female
athletes can make more money and
overseas you know they're more
appreciated overseas than they are here
right
so
she um
you know she was detained in the moscow
airport
because she had possession of a vape
cartridge containing less than a gram of
cannabis oil
so she probably vapes and she has one of
these like pens and she probably had one
of the little things and she had it in
there and she claims that she forgot
about it totally understandable because
if you vape regularly you're probably
you know you got those things all over
the place it's uh weed is illegal in
russia i don't understand that but it is
what it is
reid is you know illegal in russia so
they stay stopped her now with the war
in ukraine going on and and tension
between the united states and russia i
think that they're using her as some
sort of political
political uh prisoner this is all
political theater
she got sentenced to nine years for less
than a gram of cannabis oil i don't care
what country you're in it sounds
excessive and ridiculous okay
so what are we talking about you know
and so now as you can see on this thing
that i have on the screen they want to
trade her
for this guy um they call him the
merchant of death
um
yeah he was like this what's the guy's
name
um
oh man where is it i had it right here
because i had
victor bought whatever his name is
apparently some arms dealer you know
just a guy who's done some bad stuff he
was captured so now russia wants to
trade you know trade for you know and i
get it
so it's like what do we do
you know
it's like this how it's going to go i
mean it's such a it's such a difficult
situation to be in i mean the simple
answer is oh yeah just trade them who
cares but then that sets a precedent you
know it's like we have this policy of
like not negotiating with terrorists
and why do we have this policy because
the moment you negotiate with terrorists
then there's gonna be more terrorism
then you know more people hijack planes
and do all this stuff because they're
like well the united states will just
pay i mean that's just how that goes you
know and so you have there's one school
of thought of being like hey we can't
kowtow to this but on the other hand
we're talking about you know one of our
american citizens uh
you know uh a hero to some that are like
she just made a mistake and now she's
gonna suffer nine years in in some
foreign prison i mean as part of us it's
like i think we should you know maybe we
should make this trade or
or or make put something else in the
deal we need some draft picks or
something you know what i'm saying like
it sounds like the this is very similar
to like the kevin durant but you know
being facetious but you know what i mean
it's like we got to get equal value you
know or or what we think this is it's
like
i don't know
i mean i just i really i really don't
know like i don't know how to feel about
it because like i say on one hand you
want to be like let's do everything we
can to save her right and then on the
other hand if you think it politically
if you're one of those type of people
that thinks about big picture
you might be like we can't let that guy
go
we let that guy go and then he goes on
to do some other horrible stuff then
what do you do you know
it's like you think of star trek the
needs of the one outweigh the needs of
the many
uh that's how so they would do the trade
in star trek i just i just don't know i
don't know how you guys feel
uh you got to put that down and then
part of me also feels like
are not enough news outlets talking
about this sports and is that a good
thing to talk about it because if we are
talking about it does that make russia
feel like yeah we're getting to them and
now we're going to put pressure or is it
like why aren't we talking about it
because people don't care
you know i know a lot of you feel like
you know the trolls always are like like
as if i like to talk about race but i i
if you know me you know i'm very in the
middle about a lot of things you know
i'm very like i like to be very common
sense a leveled approach
but i gotta feel like if this was a
straight white woman
if she was a straight white good-looking
you know white woman in the wnba
and this was happening i kind of feel
like
it might be bigger
you know
so
who knows man who knows
who knows how
what people feel about this
i don't know what your thoughts are if
you guys are listening right now if
you're listening and watching
you know you might you might have some
thoughts about it you know don't you
don't got to comment on what i think i'm
asking you what are your thoughts
like i said there's the big political
picture you want might want to think
about if you're that type of person
thinking down the road
or
you could be someone that is just you
know the human experience the human side
of it is that damn
she suffered enough
for less than a gram
i bring her back you know
um there's also the side of it of like
what i'm saying is like are we not
talking about this
enough
is it a racial element or is it just
that hey maybe we don't need to let them
know
this bugs us
you know so we just kind of like hey
let's secretly
you know like i don't think that they
should have released the information
about who they wanted to release and all
that stuff i think they could have just
done that on the slide not let us worry
about it but once you put it out there
now you know we as american people have
to sit here and be like all right do we
want to do this
you know i don't know
there i'm sure there's people out there
who think like that like nah man we're
not letting this
you know person that caused
death and destruction for one
basketball player you know there could
be people that feel like that how do i
feel about it after saying all this
stuff about it
i think we got to get her back at all
costs you know let's just get her back
let's get her back
show
you know that we care about our people
no matter who they are and just get her
back
they should just inject him with
something you know what i mean
you know maybe something like you know
look at me like like this was a movie if
it were a movie that's how i would do it
the movie plot would be
i would inject him with some sort of
like
poison that takes a long time to
you know what i mean and then we go yeah
we're gonna do the trade you know what i
mean and then like all of a sudden he
gets sick like you know
you know what i mean or like i don't
know that that's how the movie would go
but you know it is what it is i mean we
they already we already got people over
there that are going to war and
oligarchs and all that kind of stuff so
you know get this guy out of our hair go
you send him away you know go deal with
him what's what's he doing
he's doing it are you suffering in
prison or what what does it matter you
know what i mean at this point so
uh i mean i listen i know i see people
in the chat talking about like listen i
honestly think she made a mistake she
knows she's
she lived in russia for eight years
going back and forth playing basketball
she knows the rules
i'm sure guys
that people have come in and out of
russia
had a mistake like that and they you
know i'm sure there's times they've been
like you know you can't have this and
they throw it away
this feels political
for such a small amount there's a story
of a young girl who was actually trying
to smuggle
19 grams of weed in the country
something a way larger amount she got
one month and then she was let go
this woman got nine years so
whether she knew it was legal or not i'm
one i'm positive she understood the laws
in russia and it's probably she's
probably done this like it was no big
deal two
i honestly feel like if it's just a
cartridge i totally get why when you're
packing and moving back and forth you're
a weed smoker you forgot that the
cartridge was there it's not like they
found a kit
it'd be one thing if she had like a full
kit with six cartridges and she had two
pens and she was like ready to do her
weed in in russia no
i feel like this was an honest mistake
and i don't think she should suffer for
it
nine years like so listen i find it
ridiculous all the people that are
blaming her
like all the people that are blaming her
as if like oh you should know better
it's like like i said
if she was
if she had a suitcase
you know what i mean like like like i'm
saying even if it was like a like like
like a full-on pen with like everything
with it and she was trying to get that
in then yeah you're like what you doing
you should know better but this was
clearly a mistake
it obviously was a mistake
you know what i mean so
it feels political and it feels like
something needs to happen and
you know
that's how i feel about it and i hope
that i feel for her and her family and
let's hope that you know this is somehow
resolved and where everybody can feel
you know it you know we also have to
remember that like you know not
everywhere is the united states
yes we feel like we have the best system
and democracy and freedoms and you know
our justice system and our due process
it feels fair
our system feels fair and just
not everywhere in the world feels the
same way about a lot of things race
culture
homosexuality
religion
other places in the world have a
completely different idea about
what is right and wrong and we have to
remember that when we leave the united
states we're not traveling in the united
states anymore and we have to abide by
rules of the land
whether we agree with them or not
you know
like this this idiot right here in the
chat okay
i am not misinformed
of cour i just said of course she knew
the laws
she it was a little cartridge it wasn't
like she had a whole kit of marijuana
that she was trying to get in
if she did that
and tried to get that in we would be
like oh that's dumb you know you can't
get that in
this feels like
uh she was you know in in wherever she
was she had her thing she's packing she
forgot to take this out or you know what
i mean it just was a little cartridge
from a thing it feels like a mistake
it's like [ __ ] off you know what i mean
like you people
sometimes you guys
you have no
common sense
or idea of how to listen and have a
discourse
about discussing something it's either
you feel
she
on purpose
brought
less than a gram of oil because she was
oh i'm bringing this little gram of
water i'm gonna try to sneak this in
if you believe that that's what she was
trying to do
fine
then that that's what you believe but
don't talk about what how i feel about
it don't tell me about being misinformed
i'm telling you straight up i feel like
the [ __ ] was a mistake she made a
mistake
i believe her because that's what she
said
she said she she's obviously says she
knows the laws and rules and it just
happens
with all that's going on in the world
politically if you think nine years is
fair for this look at my face you're an
idiot
okay
and and and your intention by saying
that makes me feel something about you
anyways
idiots
all right let's go to some other news
more lighthearted stuff
look at this
warner brothers
discovery
so you know
the dc universe is trying to uh
they had this news about you know
they are trying to
have a 10-year plan
to make movies and you know i think just
i think it's like
they saw
what
marvel has done what marvel has created
the 13 years of what they did it paid
off huge and it's gonna be a part of our
lives forever where we're gonna look
back and be like man they really set
that up great
there were some misses in there but it
still was part of the story you know if
i look at marvel i feel like
the
i didn't like the first captain america
i thought that was a movie you got iron
man 3
you know what i mean thor 2 dark world
you know there was just a few movies
within there that you go okay but all
those movies added to the general
overall story in this grand plan of
infinity wars and end game and i thought
they did a fabulous job you know so dc
tried but they skipped too many steps
they went back they went superman batman
wonder woman uh aquaman they did justice
league uh let's have flash and then it
just didn't work out terrible lex luthor
like all the movies all that stuff that
they just it just failed it's just like
we just weren't interested
they should have taken their time
take your time man
give us a superman movie you gotta miss
the wonder woman movie give us some
batman story give you got the aquaman
give us some cyborg show us flash so
show us some other stuff you know like
build it up we'll wait we waited 13
years for marvel we'll wait [ __ ] [ __ ]
10 13 years for this too we just want it
to be good you know it's it's it's hard
this is a hard thing to do is to to to
make a movie franchise
work it's you know you know what i mean
so we know how hard it is
you know i hear some people think some
people love captain america one okay
fine but
it is what it is
so i think that i don't know how i feel
about this plan i have zero faith in the
the makers of dc movies that's just
how i feel about it
i tell you how hard it is
marvel's not doing a great job right now
after end game losing robert downey jr
and losing chris evans as captain
america losing those two guys
the the the foundation of the their
avengers
you know those two guys really
were the the the you know the tent poles
of this series
losing them
they just they're not doing a a fabulous
job i feel you know they had the the
doctor strange that guy cumberbatch he's
a great actor
he's he's up there of like being able to
carry it but i just didn't like that
movie
i like the movie as a standalone movie
i've actually watched it a few times
just on disney plus
if you just watch it as a standalone
movie you're like okay but like in terms
of like leading to stuff that i want to
see to me it didn't do a very good job
so now i don't know where they're going
you know then you got eternals the
eternals the the the all this like you
know
nonsense and eternals like i just don't
i don't agree with what the eternals
look like i don't agree that how the
story goes that you would have those
people be the eternals right i just feel
like that's ridiculous why would why
would this why would arisham this god
creature create these people like this i
just don't get that
you know
so i but again
that movie though another movie that
i've watched numerous times just as a
standalone movie i go okay eternals
isn't
terrible you know what i mean i just
don't like some of the statements they
made in it like you know this like
inclusion for the sake of it without any
explanation you know why would he make a
middle-aged latina woman be
a 7 000 year old woman with a latino
accent what
seven thousand-year-old robot that has a
latino accent that hasn't been invented
yet
you know what i'm saying
i what so anyway
anyways
you know
i just every time i think about it
so then now and then like this last
store the last door again enjoyable
standalone movie i don't know what this
does for the overall story of like
avengers and all the things that they're
planning so
i think even marvel so did so i could
see dc being like this is our chance to
jump in and figure it out i haven't seen
nope yet and i will be watching that
soon to uh give my review of that i just
been busy man i just been busy and i
haven't had a chance to go to the movies
and watch the movies that i want to see
but
and by the way guys um if you want to
send me if you are a producer
if you are a producer of music and you
want to share
your music with me
you know for for the podcast
uh please
i'd be more than happy to
you know get your music
i have some oh man i forgot who made
some of these
some of these beats that i have before i
have to like find the people maybe i'll
find it before i
actually let me use one from somebody
that we already know who it is
my guy chris you
you know chris hughes he's made i've
already used his beats like a couple
times and he's got some really he got
some dope beats dude so
that's gonna be the end of the show i
appreciate you guys
watching
appreciate you guys watching and
listening to riffin with griffin make
sure you subscribe
share
hit the notifications please i love all
that i'm on twitch daily check me out on
twitch eric griffin gaming and hit me up
be a youtube member be a patreon member
be a
a subscriber on twitch or even be a
super chat super twitter member there's
super twitter they have there's always
kind of ways to monetize stuff but you
know
but anyways
another fresh chris you beat
hey hey ripping with griffin is back
again
tell your friends
this is the rap recap
step up and you get slapped
kevin durant want to get traded
he not elated
[Music]
that's how we do it
[Music]
book club
make sure you watch the book club and
listen
to christopher nuttall
and all the books i talked about and
we're back
all right y'all
i got to tell chris to make the beats
longer
[Laughter]
because the beats just be ending
abruptly but anyways that's how we do it
thanks for watching we're from with
griffin and i will see you next week